cat you have a snake tattoo yeah i have
a snake touch do you love
snakes uh no badass uh no all of the men
in my family are heavily tattooed
growing up and they all had some form of
snake or dragon so i
it reminds me of home that's fair that's
cool
my grandpa was terrified of snakes and
he had a big big ass snake around a
knife on his forearm he also had a
panther that's why i got the panther my
sister has snakes too she has a medusa
tattoo so she has a bunch of snakes
right here she and i have like you have
something there too
i have some right here and she she has
it right here yeah she has it right here
and then it's like snakes all here yeah
it's like medusa's face and then snakes
everywhere
are are the men in your family tough uh
yes yeah yeah
a lot of men in and out of prison when i
was growing up ah yeah
so some gangster activity and they have
tattoos
huh yeah a lot of times prison cats some
some prison tats or
these men uncles yeah like mostly uncles
cousins
stuff like that chin just has the one
tattoo
oh yeah are you going to get your neck
tattoo i'm still waiting for the
the right artist i still want to get a
neck pet dude what tattoo did you get
with brendan and jay in uh ireland it's
like a horseshoe oh
we sort of all the shows y'all just have
this horseshoe hershey a horseshoe
why because it's lucky i don't know why
we just picked that one then
i was like don't get out because we were
gonna get clovers
like that's not irish dude we don't do
that here we're like no
he's like we don't do clovers he's like
that's an american thing that you guys
think we're going to do
or something he's like yeah yeah we're
getting a shamrock he's like this please
don't get that
he goes i'm not going to do that then he
won't give chin uh
the tattoo on his neck either he was
your first one not doing your neck
really stand up guy yeah good for him
he's like you know you're not getting
any lame irish tattoo
i like this shamrock or yeah he's like
it's not happening
well it's your [ __ ] i would have
still loved it dude i would have loved
it what do you want on your goddamn neck
i mean it's changing now that i've had
time to think about it yeah i was gonna
get the coverage uh
my girl got these these tattoos i put
one here my son put some on she got like
these
high tech tattoos that you the temporary
time oh yeah they last for
like a couple weeks yeah this one's been
on for i don't know what time it looks
pretty
we uh yeah it's been about a week if i
get a tattoo i'm gonna get a fake one
first see what it looks like
that's the point of uh those new tattoos
so you can kind of have it as a test run
with my
holes i put one on my girl well you got
your eyelids done shaking your tattoo
so but my girl did uh my girl did one
she went she was like let's see how it
looks here i put it there
it's a good thing this temporary tattoo
so i was like well let's not do that
forever
because yeah chin was just a bad look
my girlfriend actually drew what what i
wanted sort of kind of on my neck which
is what again
i mean she could drop decently what is
it again is it a dolphin or something
i was like a fish then it changed to
something else i forgot what it was jing
kills fish dude but then i looked at it
i took a picture of her she took a
picture and i was like it looks pretty
dope why don't you get something tough
like a
[ __ ] no i was the worst i think it's
the worst thing people do with tattoos
trying to
get a [ __ ] um dragon yeah like ah
yeah i like martial i like art arty
stuff artists nature
art get a waterfall get it get a
get a [ __ ] fish i would do fishing
stuff for sure
oh yeah yeah get it
no write a song and then get those
musical notes i've seen musical notes
and i've seen microphones with the wire
too much
too much i think yellow cool j has the
microphone yeah which i i just don't
i'm gonna get a stool on a mic
you're supposed to get a tattoo quite
some time ago i was and we got the 10
million downloads i know but what did
you
get years ago i don't know dude that's
for you to figure out you know
watch your small one inside your arm
okay
i can't think of a [ __ ] thing i want
you under the knife for your lids
you get a small lids were different why
because
apparently i was gonna have to get it
done i'm not violence papa if you were
in the
if you're in the midwest this would
never happen no i was all hooded
i was going to have trouble getting i
was going to get to a point where you
wouldn't be able to see my eyes that's
not true
and now my eyes are tight
now my eyes are tight it's weird you
still got the hoods
i got the hoods right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] disrespect